To solve this problem by multiplication
you do not multiply by 12,
not really at least,
you actually multiply by 1.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Because multiplying by 1
never changes our number.
3 cartons times 1.
So what next?
Well I have a very special version
of 1 that I'd like to use,
one that we just came up with.
12 eggs divided by 1 carton, and
I'm free to do this because hey,
this is equal to 1.
And now something interesting happens.
Because cartons is up here and carton is
down here, it's like a common factor.
And common factors simplify,
they cancel out.
Now what I'm left with is 3
times 12 eggs, divided by 1.
Well division by 1 never changes
anything, so let's just get rid of that.
And 3 times 12.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's just 36.
So 3 kinds of eggs is
really equal to 36 eggs.
And we got it by multiplying by 1,
or a special version of 1.
And we call that version
a conversion factor.